i recently received a challenge that was
just too juicy to resist i got a comment
on my video why i no longer have a tv
and skye made a very good point stating
that it's pointless to remove one bad
habit only to replace it with another
bad habit which i completely agreed with
and i actually have addressed in my
video my five new healthy habits and
then also my social media withdrawal
video but i found this comment really
intriguing because anybody that has ever
seen any of my videos will know that i
do not believe technology is evil i
think that technology can be very
helpful but there's a distinct
difference between us using technology
and technology using us for example if
i'm using technology to learn about
parenting and improve my parenting
skills then i view it as a good thing it
can be helpful but now if i use
technology as a distraction and my
daughter's asking me for dinner and i
tell her me how
your dinner's gonna have to wait i'm
learning about parenting then the
dynamic changes and i think that it can
be really easy to fall into these gray
zones when we have technology around us
every day at the touch of our fingertips
so sky
challenge accepted i'm going to go for
two weeks with no internet no cell
service and no television but first let
me explain why i thought this was a
great idea to begin with if you have
ever had any type of digestive ailment
like pancreatitis for example you'll
know that one of the first things that a
doctor does is puts you on a diet
basically you can't eat anything and the
reasoning behind this is that it allows
your body to have a restoration period
instead of focusing on the digestive
processes well i kind of thought the
same as far as technology i'm constantly
using technology every single day so i
kind of see this challenge as a reset
period a time to analyze how i'm using
it am i using it to my advantage and to
those around me and just to really be
more mindful as far as the specifics i
have to be very clear that this is not
during my regular routine type of time
i'm actually going to be on vacation and
i specifically planned it out this way
because for me it is not possible to go
without technology when i'm working
because i'm a home nurse i need a gps to
be able to get to my patients homes i
need a computer to be able to document
and order supplies i need internet for
that i need to be able to call doctors
and all those sorts of things and so
that just would not be possible plus if
i'm working about 100 miles away i
better know where my kids are and how
they're doing so a cell phone is a must
however in order to prepare for this i
actually did go ahead and just let my
family and close friends know that i'm
not going to be available so that they
don't think that i just ghosted them or
i'm ignoring them for some sort of
reason for the two weeks i will not be
able to use a television which we don't
even own a television so that's not hard
but we'll include it just for kicks and
giggles
computer no internet or cell phone which
cell phone i think is the biggest one
it's just all around us every single day
right
but then also commodities like things
like our smart thermostat and our smart
lamp
i'm going to have to actually get up to
turn off my lamp you guys how will i
survive
let's talk about expectations so i think
i can survive without my smart bulb i
i'm gonna be okay you guys but i've come
to think about
i'm gonna miss my audiobooks
so right now i am off to work i drive so
much to work but even when i'm not going
to faraway places i find that audiobooks
makes my drive much more enjoyable and i
feel like i'm learning something i'm
doing something more productive with my
time and i really really enjoy
audiobooks when i'm driving so that's
something that i think i'm gonna miss
that in the notes section on my phone i
use the heck out of my notes section so
i'm thinking i'm going to be looking a
little bit nerdy and probably using like
a small little notebook and carrying
around with me everywhere i go because
i feel like if i don't write something
down i'm going to forget it so that's
like my brain i have to carry it with me
my calendar i live off of my calendar
google calendar you guys if you haven't
had that you need to do it and start it
because you can share that with other
individuals that can also access the
account so you can schedule things on
there and they can see them as well so
for example my mom is my nanny which is
so amazing but she can see the days that
i work my husband can edit things so if
we have if he wants to schedule a dinner
date hinted
then he can do so on google calendar so
i live off of that and so now i'm gonna
have to just live off of a little
notebook that i just carry everywhere i
go because again
i have a difficult time remembering
things okay and of course obviously
internet is amazing and awesome and i'm
probably gonna miss that a lot but i'm
really excited for this experience today
is my last day of the work week before
my vacation begins so we will see how
excited i am once it actually begins we
shall see
good morning
it is 5 45 right now and my morning has
long commenced my little alarm clock
john has already had his pre-breakfast
breakfast
and
last night i actually turned my phone
off and placed it inside my bedside
table and this morning when i got up i
realized i guess i had like my little
ritual that i didn't realize
i didn't have my flashlight and i missed
that so this morning i kind of had to
spiel for my stuff and my clothes when i
got up this morning
i feel like i've said this morning too
many times listen let me get some water
and then get some coffee and then we can
chat
[Music]
okay i have my latte now we are good to
go
so i really like to learn about habits
changing negative habits adopting new
habits and one of the things that i have
learned is that when you're trying to
adopt a new habit that's not necessarily
easy to do or it doesn't really provide
you joy that you mix it with something
that does provide pleasure and joy for
example waking up early was not
something that i always loved to do and
now it's something that i am actually
excited to do because it's my me time
it's my latte time after i drink my
water or even just simple things like
lighting a candle that make me happy to
get up early in the morning
so for me right now i'm actually excited
that i don't have a phone for
distractions because we are going on
about an eight hour road trip to visit
my unofficially adopted mom at the beach
so i need to do some packing i need to
fix my hair situation and put some
makeup on my face so let me do all those
things and recap with you later
our trip started off anything but
perfect we had an accident on the way
and ended up in the emergency room with
a seven hour detour however thankfully
everybody was okay and we did not use
cell phones to distract either ourselves
or our kids during that seven hour wait
we were truly just happy that we were
okay and we took that time to reflect
and be grateful and we were also
grateful that we would soon be back on
the road and see what the rest of our
trip would be like
i think something that definitely helped
during this specific time of the
challenge is that i went into it with an
open mind i didn't have this negative
expectation of what it would be like and
i was just open for whatever happened
and surprisingly to me the first few
days were actually very easy i actually
wanted to go without my phone and i
think one of the things that helped is
that my husband decided that he would
join me
on
this challenge as well now he did use
his phone for calls and things like that
but as far as entertainment he was
joining me in and so it didn't feel like
it was just me there was definitely a
greater focus on
relationships on building experiences
and just being present and in the moment
and because i wasn't doing it alone it
was just that much better because i had
somebody to talk to about it and that
could understand me
that we could relate to each other
during this time i also did some work on
just focusing more on increasing
my self-awareness and i started
journaling as well i have a 12-week
planner that has questions listed out on
it that has really just made me ask
myself deeper questions about who i am
what it is that i want in life and so i
really took this
to heart i didn't want for this
challenge to just be
about
going without technology and then what i
wanted it to be deeper than that and so
i started to
really dig in into my personal life my
relationships and focusing on
relationships and that's one thing that
i think also helped as well
is that the people that we were
surrounded by were just very positive
people that inspired us and that we
wanted to be more like
and i think that when we are surrounded
by individuals that have the opposite
effect the negative nancy's it makes it
10 times more difficult to take steps to
improve your life to change negative
habits
and so for me those two things
definitely helped me during this time
being surrounded by people that make me
want to be a better version of myself
and then also having my husband join me
and hold me accountable for the habits
that i was trying to improve
so diving deeper into habits building
positive habits i
very much believe that when you change
one aspect of your life it truly affects
all aspects if you
have a horrible diet it's going to
reflect on your mood on your behaviors
it's going to make you more grumpy more
irritable
if you have by contrast an
i don't know physical health then it's
going to give you more energy it's going
to make you feel more positive more
happy it's going to balance your
hormones it's going to affect all
platforms so if you decide you're going
to start to save money then maybe you're
going to be less stressed out you're
going to be a better spouse
i think that when you change one thing
positively it has like a domino effect
on other aspects of your life so in this
scenario i decided that if i was going
to remove technology
and remove this focus on technology for
this period of time
then i wanted to add some more positive
habits or really improve the habits that
i already have to begin with and one of
those is reading i chose to read a
particular book that i've already read
before and it is crucial conversations
this book i think i read it about three
years ago i ended up buying a copy i
gave it to somebody because i thought it
was so helpful but then after i gave it
away i realized i want to read it again
and so i purchased it again and it has
definitely been a life-changing book and
dare i say life-saving so the most
recent conversation that i for me was
very crucial that i can give you an
example of is about two months ago i was
driving to a patient's home as a home
nurse and it truly seemed like a day
straight out of a horror movie i mean i
can laugh at it now but it was not funny
then i basically drove into the woods
lost cell service my gps quit working so
i got lost it was a rainy foggy day it
was a dirt road with puddles that i
thought for sure i was going to get
stuck in
and along comes a one-eyed man tattooed
everywhere and a little buddy on his hip
who let's just say did not seem very
happy and he told me to get out of his
property
or else and let's just say i don't think
he meant or else he was gonna invite me
for a cup of tea
so i try my best to get out of his
property and find my way to where i
actually needed to go but somehow i
ended up right back to him oh my
goodness
he did not look happy that time either
so this time he proceeds to threaten my
life five years ago this conversation
would have led me into a panic attack
however unfortunately as a nurse over
the years i've had a lot of
opportunities to put crucial
conversations and the lessons that i've
learned into practice and i was able to
see his perspective and maintain calm
while also expressing my perspective and
at the end of this conversation he
actually helped me get to where i needed
to go
talk about a life-saving book so this is
a book that i highly highly highly
recommend um because conversations truly
shape our lives i mean a conversation
can lead to a divorce a conversation can
lead to an argument a conversation can
lead to a resolution of an argument so
it can really shape your life completely
so highly recommend it the link is in
the description in case you're
interested
about the midway point i started to feel
a little bit differently about this
challenge and i call it the breakthrough
point because this is when the feeling
started to shift it was no longer
exciting this was no longer something
that i was enjoying it was something
that i started to question why i did
this to begin with i really wanted to
stop and i thought that i was having
unnecessary discomfort so let me explain
that i started to feel disconnect i saw
my sister for example and she said i
miss having you to be able to talk to
you i wanted to tell you something and i
could tell that we needed to have a
conversation and i wasn't able to do
that during that time that i didn't have
my phone which made me kind of sad i
feel like i've missed out you know the
fomo um but connections with people
there would be times when i just wanted
to google a question to something that
would be really simple that i could have
an answer within about a minute or so
and i couldn't do so or i would have an
awesome experience and i would want to
share it with my family and i couldn't
do so or i wanted to speak with a family
member about something just to check on
them and see how they're doing i
couldn't do that
just a lot of little things along the
way that i felt like
would
make my life a little bit better they're
not necessarily bad things that i
couldn't do and so i started to feel
like
uh why am i doing this why did i do this
to myself i just want this to be over
and so besides reading journaling and
running around after two kids what i did
during this time to try to keep my mind
occupied on positive things was my
version of spring cleaning and
inspiration for the new year
i wanted this time to not only be a
mental reset but also make it so for our
home so i did some decluttering a deep
clean of the entire home and i also took
on a few small projects to reduce visual
clutter
one example is our open laundry room it
had bright blue bins and i painted those
black to match our jars
and maybe it's a bit weird but i also
painted our detergent lids to make
everything more cohesive and i removed
the labels on the detergent and labels
on products all throughout the house
sometimes when we declutter we forget
about visual clutter and so i took this
time to give our home a refresh too
this kept me busy and content during the
last few days of the challenge when it
was especially difficult
there are definitely aspects of this
challenge that has helped me but overall
i think it really has helped me have a
greater gratitude
for the technology that i have the fact
that i have a microwave the fact that i
have smart bulbs and i don't have to get
up and turn off my lamp it's not
necessary to have that i mean i lived in
a time where we didn't have a microwave
my husband didn't even know what a
refrigerator was when he was a kid
certainly these things aren't
necessities like we
sometimes feel they are we can go
without them
but it makes me appreciate it so much
more because it does make my life easier
it does improve my life and it does
improve my connections because i have
family that lives far away and i can
just call them up on my phone and
actually see their face which wasn't
something that we were able to do
maybe 10 years back and so i think this
has helped me
definitely have a greater appreciation
of it
but it doesn't make me feel like i need
to stop using technology i think if
anything it has really helped me to
realize that i need to be aware of how i
use it
when i'm using it am i using it to my
advantage to better my health my
relationships those of the people around
me my hope with all of this is that you
will also join on a technology fast
whether that be quitting video games for
a week or going without your phone for a
weekend or maybe just something simple
like for example
no answering phone calls or text
messages or touching the phone during
meal times that's something that my
husband and i have actually done ever
since we got married and i love that it
kind of makes it feel like we're still
on a date and i think it also respects
family time
so much more that way so it could be
something simple but one tip that i
would have for you if you are going to
have an extended technology fast is to
be very cautious and make sure that you
have some sort of a support because some
of us
have emotional struggles that we're
suppressing through the use of
technology and when all of a sudden you
don't have technology you're just left
with you and your thoughts and your
thoughts may not necessarily be positive
helpful ones um you know what i mean if
if you've had this experience
and so just have somebody that you can
go to because it's similar to a
workaholic for example that has lots of
problems in their family and they go to
work all the time to escape having to
deal with those problems well then
they're on vacation and what do they do
they bicker with their family or do they
actually work through problems so this
could be similar situation have somebody
that you can go to or a way that you can
process through these feelings that may
arise for example if you start to feel
lonely and even better if you could have
somebody that could kind of hold you
accountable and encourage you along the
way so hopefully you can go on a
technology fast of your own and let me
know what it will be i hope that this
challenge was of some value to you if so
please give it a thumbs up and help
support my channel and subscribe so that
you won't miss out on my future videos
and let me know what challenge you are
going to take on until next time bye